[Music]
let's go to shawn in north carolina sean
hey what's going on man
hey john i'm glad to be on the show well
i'm glad that you called brother
what's up all right so i am a young
manager 23 years old
and i have to go and confront him play
about racist comments he made
i've initially talked to him and found
out he has a pretty homogeneous
upbringing that
influences his words he works hard but
his comments are often insensitive
okay i don't necessarily want to fire
him immediately but i have to counsel
him
and talk to him and then potentially
recommend him for dismissal how do i go
about this
oh so what are some of the things
man what are you working on what's your
job what's your trade i like
construction
construction okay so what is
he talking about what's he saying he
went up to one of his
direct supervisors and said that most
black people are lazy and don't work
hard
why what what precipitated that he
oftentimes when i notice him and hear
him i don't talk to him directly too
much
he is one of those people who always
just brings up stuff he really
shouldn't talk about at work he's always
bringing up just politics
and just says things that are always out
of place
and i just don't know how to go about it
he works hard but it's just his comments
consistently
are just not workplace appropriate out
of place
um do you have people of color on your
crew
yeah it's about half and it's just
causing issues in the workplace and i
don't know if i should just
recommend them for dismissal immediately
the the company policies basically i
have to counsel him twice
yeah and then i could recommend him it's
just
i it his upbringing i ate listen listen
listen i could care less what his
upbringing is
could care less not an excuse don't care
it makes me compassionate or empathetic
but i don't care um
yeah so here's the deal i don't care how
hard of a worker somebody is
if they disparage people on my team
if they disparage potential and that may
be a direct disparagement like pointing
at somebody and saying something
insensitive and stupid
not insensitive just stupid and
factually wrong some things that hurt
people or
they say something that could impact
somebody else's dad or their mom or
their brother or whatever
i don't care how good of a worker they
are
they will unwind any sort of team morale
team support and overall team unity that
helps you get a job done
so you can be the best worker in the
world you're gonna be on my team
go work by yourself and so
uh my guess is that you sanitize that
for
me just now this guy can get pretty raw
absolutely and it's always just out he's
one of those people and even a regular
conversation just stuff he says is like
why would you say that
yeah um stupid comments all the time and
i feel like some of this
with me is that my fiance tells me
sometimes i treat people like projects
and i've been told by my subordinates
that sometimes i'm a little too soft on
people yep
and that's like where this comes in my
development as a young manager who's
been promoted a couple times in the last
years i feel like i have a lot of
responsibility i'm trying to deal with
this i've dealt with a sexual harassment
issue before
yeah so um
three things in in my experience
dissolve team unity faster than anything
theft
and dishonesty
any sort of racial or
cultural disparagement breaking people
down
for the way they talk the way they dress
the way they just their presence their
being
right and then any sort of sexual
harassment
not being able to come to work and feel
safe or
knowing that hey this guy's holding a
ladder for me
and i wouldn't let him around my sister
i don't trust him like that
so i'm always going to be up that ladder
with one eye open does that make sense
so
those three things i have no quarter for
as a leader you're done get out of here
and what you lose in productivity from
one person you will gain in team unity
almost 100 of the time and even then i
don't care
because i'm going to do the right thing
even if it hurts me and my team
and so what i want to empower you to do
is to find those things those
what i would call values
man at construction site talk politics i
have been on a number of constructions
especially when i was younger man i
talked in a way on a construction site
man you language flies
that's one thing that's a construction
site right that is different than
disparaging people because of the way
they look right
and so i would be really clear about who
you're going to be what kind of manager
you're going to be what kind of leader
you're going to be what you're going to
tolerate
and then man as a 23 year old you're
going to get tested right out of the
gate with some 48 year old
tradesman who's really good at what he
does who's going to lean into this 23
year old and say i dare you
and everybody's going to be watching
sean
and you know who's going to be watching
everyone's going to be watching
but the most important person watching
is that guy you look in the mirror
right you're right so listen
um you can hold
other people's pain and trauma right you
can hold it
you cannot manage the outcome so at some
point one of those guys is going to come
in there and say hey my wife's
um really sick and you're going to say
get out of here and go be with your wife
go take care of her
and then somebody's gonna follow up two
weeks later and say hey i want three
weeks off too because
and you can tell them shut your mouth
your time will come and i'll be there to
support you
right um but if that guy never comes
back
you still did the right thing okay
right but if i'm you i'd be in this
i wouldn't even be in this guy's face
i'm not gonna meet that kind of muscle
with muscle
that's that's meeting fire with fire
that's a full
frontal assault those things never work
everybody dies
that guy's going to come into my office
and sit down at my thing and i'm going
to lean across the desk and say
if you make another racial statement on
this site you are finished at this
company
period end of conversation or if you
have to
as hr says you have to counsel somebody
you will say this is your one warning
you will not divide this team up you
won't treat people that way you're not
going to make stupid stereotypical
racial nonsense
crap you're going to spread that poison
around my job site not in my sight
go work somewhere else but they'll
tolerate that crap not here
okay you can disparage women on my site
get out because i'm not going to have
that because i got a mom i got a sister
i got a wife not going to do it and
here's what's a cool thing for a guy
like you
people are your projects whenever
somebody starts spewing poison like that
on your team i want you to think of the
other
40 guys as your project not that one
those are the guys that you need to keep
safe and well
and make sure that they've got a place
where they can show up and work their
butt off every day
not that they all have to put up with
this one idiot right
now i've been harsh i also want to give
people this
one sliver of grace
i will call somebody in and say you may
not know this so here's your benefit of
the doubt
we don't say that here we don't talk
that here this isn't
funny here i've done that at every
single job i've ever been to
sometimes people are being jerks
sometimes people just didn't know
and um that's me using my role
and i i'd like to think of it using my
role for good and i hope you can do that
too
so wrap my head around this picture
how's that gonna go you're gonna call
him and then what's gonna happen next
i'm gonna call him i'm gonna go over the
policies some we don't tolerate that
here
because it's just gonna affect everyone
else on the site it's not acceptable
it's not tolerable
and if he does it again he's getting
fired
so i want to challenge you on something
okay
on this one you have to follow policies
but don't hide behind him
okay this is a virtue and value thing
now you don't have to do this but i'd
love to see you go one extra notch and
say
i'm tired of you disparaging people on
this site
because of their race and culture
it's wrong it's not right it's not how
we treat people
and from this point forward that that
behavior is done it's over if i hear
about it again you're out of here
and then you can go back to here's the
policies and stuff but anytime somebody
starts policy with me i feel like
they're hiding from
a hard conversation and this is one that
i think is a big enough deal
and then i would loop everybody back
into that and call everybody into a team
meeting if you all have those
and say i've addressed some of you
this will not happen here y'all can joke
around have fun i want this to be crazy
obviously i can bring kids to a
construction site right
but we're not gonna we're not doing this
does that sound good yes john thank you
for the advice on it hey man
this is one of those uh defining moments
when you're gonna find out about
yourself as a leader
as a person who takes a stand for what's
right
and for whatever it's worth brother i'm
proud of you
okay thank you all right man take care
and hey
shoot me a note back and let me know how
that conversation goes it may go
awful that dude may blow up and get your
face
and say this and that and i've been
reading about it
stick to your guns do what's right and
um
hold the line on that virtue and value
man that's awesome brother that's
awesome